hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute gibt eine kleine deko
idee denn ich werde heute auf blüten
passte eine kleine krone basteln die ich
dann später auf eine geburtstagstorte
setze und diese krone hat auch schon
meine frühere freundin nicole von nicole
superweib gemacht sie hat ihre krone mit
strasssteinen danach beklebt und ich
werde meine krone jetzt erstmal weiß
machen und später dann einfach mit
goldwerten und ich zeige jetzt einmal
mein werkzeug was ich dazu brauche also
ich habe das hier blüten passte das ist
jetzt eine fertige blüten passte
ich nehme die mittlerweile ganz gerne
weil ich einfach die zeit nicht mehr
dazu habt blüten passt das selber
herzustellen
und ich habe hier einfach auch kein
rohes ei weiß mit drin und dann habe ich
hier noch ein bisschen werkzeug
ich habe mir jetzt hier zum beispiel
schon eine krone vorgezeichnet das heißt
ich habe hier ein papier genommen und
habe mir einfach eine vorlage genommen
und hab hier dieses ding aufgezeichnet
per hand und habt es dann einfach durch
gepasst habe jetzt eben zwei identische
seiten und eine krone
da ich jetzt nicht diese blüten fasste
darauf legen kann weil es darauf kleben
würde habe ich hier noch etwas wachs
papier und zwar gibt's wachs papier so
auf eine rolle
und es gibt einfach in jedem
bastelgeschäft zu kaufen auch gerne
online
da kann ich euch gerne auch was den
infobox freisetzen
wo er etwas eben erhalten können aber
wie gesagt gibt es in jedem bastelt
wahrscheinlich auch in großen
supermärkten eventuell auch in der
bastel abteilung dann habe ich hier
einen tortenring der htc etwa 14 cm im
durchmesser
ihr könnt einfach irgendwas bundes
namens kann zum beispiel auch eine
verpackung von irgendwie einer großen
dosis sein also irgendwo zwischen körper
oder irgendwas in warin gedrängt was
aber eben rund ist irgend eine dose und
dann brauche ich noch etwas panel für
die hände und zum wald kneten und zwar
habe ich hier noch meine freundin model
presse habt ihr auch mal kurz in einem
anderen video gesehen und zwar hatte ich
ja früher mal hier dieser shooter gang
mit der ich füge aber
ab zum beispiel bei der regenbogen torte
aber wahrscheinlich aber ziemlich
aufgeregt da zeige ich euch auch gleich
wieso weil die einfach nicht so gut
funktioniert mittlerweile habe ich
einfach dieses hier meine fondant presse
mein modell werkzeug da kann ich einfach
durch drehbewegungen vorne eben den
fondant raus drücken und darts
verschiedenen schalten wir dabei hier
habe ich mir jetzt drei stück ausgesucht
das sind einfach drei mit verschiedenen
stärken und alle sind eben eckig das
heißt ich möchte man ein langes band
daraus spritzen
ich nehme zielen ein papier und fettet
es ganz leicht mit diesen kann ihn
einfach damit es jetzt gleich unter dem
wachs papier kleben bleibt
dann kommt das wachs papier drüber und
jetzt bitte ich noch mein wachs papier
ganz leicht damit da gleich gefüllten
pflaster draufkleben bleibt zum
verbreiten müsst ihr jetzt einfach eure
blüten passte nehmen und mit den palmen
richtig schön weich kneten
das habe ich jetzt bereits gemacht und
ich nehme mir immer nur ganz kleine
menge und den rest bewahre ich hier in
so einer luftdichten schüssel auf damit
einfach nicht ausdrücken und ich zeige
mich jetzt einfach mal wie ich es früher
gemacht habe in meiner show gang und
wasser
die probleme waren hier muss man einfach
so eine lange rolle formen
bei beiden geräten hier kommt dann hier
unten rein und man sieht auch schon den
ersten unterschied
diese rolle ist natürlich wesentlich
kleiner und ich muss viel öfter nach
fügen als jetzt bei dieser und dann
schraubt man das hier oben fest dass ich
auch ziemlich gleich ich spreche hier
dem hier so dass man einfach hier
drücken muss und dann kommt unten raus
aber bereits wenn man das 10 11 x
gedrückt hat wird es einfach so
anstrengend und es dauert einfach
solange man kriegt hier echt krämpfe in
den händen
und vor allem galt oft stehen und da
muss man oftmals hier oben drücken damit
unten eben wieder weitergeht und das
wird eben wie gesagt mit der zeit
ziemlich anstrengend deswegen habe ich
jetzt dieses gerät vor noch zu zeigen
hier 3 aber ich benutze es einfach nicht
mehr weiter
sie sind drehen einfach viel einfacher
geht und das frage ich euch jetzt
einfach und steuerte direkt mit meiner
krone so es die baue ich jetzt kurz
auseinander und setzt da oben eine
scheibe ein und dann kann ich das hier
oben aus stehen und jetzt könnte das
hier ganz schnell runter tel
und so gedreht und jetzt könnt ihr das
ganz einfach drehen hier oben
und es ist natürlich eine ganz andere
kräfte verteilung des raus drücken
geschieht nämlich dann hier oben durch
das zwirbeln und durch das drehen
jetzt kann ich gleich im handumdrehen
richtig schnell eine ganze schlange
machen ohne dass es vorher reist ihr
könnt auch langsam machen als ich je
nachdem wie ihr das eben haben wollt
jetzt schneide ich mir das hier oben ab
denn so lange brauche ich das erste
jetzt nicht und war direkt an mit meiner
krone und jetzt muss ich mir mit meiner
von der presse immer mal wieder einen
langen strand herauspressen und den kann
ich dann auf meiner schablone also auf
der vorlage anbringen
dazu verwende ich ganz einfaches
werkzeug neben den pinsel und nehmen
etwas cmc kleber also zucker kleber
denn alle teile müssen immer miteinander
verbunden werden also verklebt werden
damit die krone später eben nicht
auseinanderfällt
jetzt müsst ihr einfach nach der vorlage
arbeiten und die stränge mit der blüten
passte einfach entlang legen
zurechtschneiden und schön aus formen
jetzt durch die krone auf mein zweites
wachs pakete aufgegeben dann ist einfach
etwas stabiler ist
den tortenring habe ich jetzt bereits
eingefettet ihr könnt auch gern etwas
höheres nehmen das vereinfacht das ganze
natürlich aber der durchmesser muss
klein sein
und jetzt kann ich das ganze hier jetzt
nehme ich die krone und setzte hier noch
auf so eine tortenplatte also auch so
ein torten retter und lasst sie jetzt so
komplett ab austrocknen etwa zwei drei
tage und dann kann ich sie erst pinsel
und müsste sie einfach irgendwo
hinstellen wo keine kinder dran kommen
wo aber auch vielleicht nicht so viel
licht dran kommt am besten in der
abstellkammer
ich wäre es glaube ich einfach bei mir
da oben auf dem kühlschrank stellen
da kommt auch keine rahmen außer mir
weil ich wie daheim begrüßte bin lasse
ich das jetzt einfach kurz trocknen für
die nächsten drei tage und dann sage ich
euch nicht so zeitig stelle
ihr könnt jetzt die krone bepinseln und
zwar entweder hier mit dieser farbe ganz
normal also bruder farbe auf die weise
krone drauf dann habt ihr den effekt
dass es einen leichten schimmer gibt und
eben nicht ganz dunkel und deckend wird
oder ihr könnt die pulver farbe einfach
mit etwas alkohol vermischen und dann
die krone eben nass damit bestreichen
das hat auch den vorteil dass dann
später die puder farbe besser
traumhaften bleibt und wenn ihr einfach
mit den fingern dran kommt färbt eben
nichts an eure finger ab danach müsst
ihr die krone natürlich nochmal komplett
trocknen lassen und sie dann einfach
noch mal dazu weg stellen oder ihr könnt
direkt die krone aus schwarzer blüten
passte machen
ich habe jetzt hier einfach ein bisschen
schwarz ausgerollt und dann kann es
nämlich das ganze mit den pulvern ab
oder und es deckt dann auch richtig gut
also da muss man es nicht vorher mit
alkohol
ich zeige es euch jetzt hier mal sieht
man hier das super und dann nimmt man
sich einfach noch mal diese farbe kann
nochmal drüber gehen um den ganzen
effekt ebenen zu verstärken kann auch
ein dunkleres dieses große gold nehmen
dann habe ich hier diesen antiken gold
effekt oder ich kann sogar beide mission
macht ihr am besten form er in so einem
schälchen aber ich kann sowieso schnell
zeigen und so kann ich das ganze
praktisch komplett ohne alkohol machen
und natürlich wenig ist die krone machen
würde und man natürlich alles abfordern
damit einfach keine schwarzen reste
bleiben
aber ich finde es hat doch immer so
schön antiken effekt immer so ein
bisschen das dunkle bis schwarze durch
sieht
die fertige krone habe ich dann einfach
auf meine torte draufgesetzt
aber da ich die torte von waghäusel nach
stuttgart transportiert habe habe ich
einfach nochmal abgenommen und hier auch
seine styropor gesetzt und einfach mit
zahnstochern fixiert da konnte ich
einfach sicherstellen dass da beim
transport nichts passiert und es ist
auch nichts passiert und jetzt hoffe ich
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat
schaut auf jeden fall auch von meiner
freundin nicole vorbei wie sie ihre
krone gemacht hat die hatten nämlich
auch richtig schön gemacht und ich
einfach so eine andere idee mit den
strasssteinen und ich hoffe dass ich das
video gefallen hat gerne durch demir
auch anregungen geben für ein nächstes
motiv torten video durch gerne wünsche
äußern
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder bis bald